[Musique]
les routes du vermont sont comme une
succession de cartes postales bucolique
au coeur des collines luxuriantes des
fermes paisible et des vaches à l'air
sympathique qui semblent saluer les
visiteurs
willem beck a grandi dans ce décor
champêtre derrière la carte postale se
cachent des travailleurs de l'ombre
90% des gens qui travaillent dans les
fermes laitières sur les mexicains sans
papiers explique celui qui consacre sa
vie à améliorer le sort de ces
travailleurs depuis l'élection de donald
trump et ses promesses de renvoyer les
immigrés les coûts sont très nerveux le
mieux est sale et la rapine et a comparé
longue et nous avons peur d'aller faire
des courses de sortir des fermes car
nous craignons que la police de
l'immigration ne nous intercepte et nous
ne vais pas faire le mexique explique ce
travailleur installé au vermont depuis
six ans avec sa femme au cours des
derniers mois deux des meilleurs copains
ont été arrêtés par cette police qu'on
appelle ici la migra les fermiers qui
dépendent de cette main d'oeuvre à bon
marché
550 dollars en moyenne pour six jours et
demi de travail sont aussi très nerveux
ils sont déconnectés à washington
explique ce fait remis en fait tout le
monde presque au vermont s'entend pour
dire que les immigrants illégaux font
ici oeuvre utile wonder sans eux les
fermiers ferait faillite
les unes ce résident du vermont will
lambeek et son organisme en ont beaucoup
contribué à faire adopter par l'état du
vermont
une mesure qui contient l'idée de base
du concept de sanctuaire pour les sans
papiers vers l'os windows des provinces
la loi interdit à la police du vermont
d'utiliser son temps et ses ressources
pour effectuer le sale travail de dans
notre homme de 32 ans
concrètement cela veut dire que la
police ne pose pas de questions sur le
statut des immigrants et ne peut
dénoncer un immigrant illégal aux
services d'immigration
même si l'ordinateur nous indique que
quelqu'un n'a pas de statut légal aux
états unis on ne retient pas et on
appelle personnes ça ne nous regarde pas
les unes le chef de police de burlington
le vice gouverneur du vermont est aussi
agriculteur il est bien conscient que
cette politique déplaît à washington à
washington on a commencé à menacer les
états et les villes qui ne collaborerait
pas avec les minorations de couper
certaines subventions liées à la
sécurité civile
on essaie de limiter le pouvoir des
états comme des villes qui ont décidé
comme de concentrer nos ressources sur
de véritables problèmes de sécurité nos
soeurs hilton devra donc notre corps
hors du temps la politique de sanctuary
à du vermont n'empêche pas la police
fédérale d'agir henrique qui très engagé
dans les activités de l'organisme de
wiland bec en sait quelque chose
le jeune homme qui vit tout vermont
depuis qu'il a 17 ans s'est fait
connaître du grand public en militant
pour que les sans papiers puissent y
obtenir un permis de conduire
en mars dernier la migra l'attendait aux
portes du local de mike brant justice il
a été détenu deux semaines et fait
maintenant face à une mesure de
déportation oui lambeek est convaincu
que ce genre de rafles sert un intérêt
économique un peu machiavélique people
were so les gens tellement peur d'être
déportés qu'ils vont accepter les
conditions de travail qu'ils
n'accepteraient pas autrement dit il
dans ce contexte et pour que la carte
postale ne soit pas qu'une illusion
d'optique
le mou sanctuaire rien ici tout son sens
[Musique]